lotto dosia tolas gracias por que dar se
hasta esta hora creo que juega las
direcciones not ova ck dobra gracias a
un saludo para mi familia que esta acha
creo hola familia ah bueno vamos a pasar
in des por que ama facil para me ah so
yeah add my talk is called sleepy map
style geo canvas design with caro CSS
and my name is a vaguely moser and i'm
from the mozilla science lab which is a
part of mozilla that build open-source
science software and its includes
geospatial geospatial scientific
software so this is making maps and all
of my slides or down at that link there
too so if you want to follow along I
have all of the links in the in the
notes below so the backgrounds isn't a
map you might have noticed it's a comic
so I'm going to reference comics as well
just like Rachel did in her talk kind of
except I'm not a comic creator i'm more
of a comic consumer but i like comics as
a metaphor for framing how we design
maps because maps are kind of built with
this similar story like cell structure
right maps are composed of tiles usually
if you're dealing with raster maps and
they kind of compose next to each other
to build a story and CSS supplies style
to that and so i'm going to talk a
little bit about how Carlos CSS kind of
gives a lot of punch and and and beauty
to maps so uh I like to start talks
talking about how we process things with
our vision our eyes are kind of
reflexive processors right they're
pretty sophisticated process or is much
more sophisticated than the machines are
at processing our 3d world understanding
depth perceiving what areas need to be
prioritized and also colorizing our
world and you don't have to write a new
rules for it depending on the quality of
your vision your eyes just kind of
naturally adjust to this right and
that's the kind of reflexive design that
we hope to achieve on the web but
there's usually some latency right
there's usually some loading screen with
web
visualizations things are kind of slow
so it's not as reflexive as with your
eyes but we'd like it to be and I'm
going to show you how we can make it
better with vector mapping too so this
is where I'm from from New York this is
a map from Wonder Woman comic I like to
start out with this too because it kind
of brings up the mythology of maps so
when you design maps you know or when
you use maps you don't really think
about how accurate they might be right
unless it's inaccurate and you know it's
inaccurate because you're in the place
that is inaccurate but really someone
had to draw that at some point even if
they had machine aids someone had to
kind of design the way we appreciate a
3d globe in a flat 2d canvas and so
there's a mythology beyond it behind it
that not a lot of people really
appreciate or they don't you know really
think about when they use maps for
navigation so it's not unlike designing
mythological maps for comics either real
mapping also relies on some assumptions
and some constraints and you kind of
have to give in to some of the errors
that are quite natural in building 2d
maps so this is the canvas that I
typically work on this is cardo or this
is osm openstreetmap who knows about
openstreetmap everyone almost hopefully
some people okay openstreetmap is kind
of like the Wikipedia for base maps
right people can go in and edit their
own communities so it's a
community-driven project and it's quite
robust in some areas and not so much in
others but I like to show this as an
animated chip because it shows me
panning and zooming left and right and
also zooming in infinitely and I don't
think people who design for the web or
even just regular you know charts and
bar graphs really think about how
complex this canvas is because you have
to design for the zoo II interface that
people expect to naturally adjust as
they zoom and they have very little
patience for it when it doesn't work and
then they pan infinitely left and right
so the canvas is infinite and and that's
a pretty serious
straight for development and also to
when it pans left you'll also see that
there are these blocks of gray let you
see right now so those are tiles loading
right so you appreciate the canvas as
being infinite because you can move but
but it's actually limited to your
browser screen usually if you're dealing
with raster maps or maps that use tiles
so this is from a talk that I saw in New
York very minimalistic slides but the
developer of a small mapping library I
think called simple tiles at ProPublica
which is a news investigative journalism
organization in in New York and he did a
lot of work with satellite imagery for
maps so he was talking about how slippy
maps which are the maps that you saw
here because you can slip around right
slippy mats slippy maps are optimized
for location and wayfinding and not for
aw which is so sad when that's what you
do for a living right you think that
someone just said at a conference that
your stuff is boring and not awesome and
it's usually utilitarian so this is a
similar block so I make a lot of maps
but I also make a lot of charts and
graphs with geodata and and I started
thinking a lot about this idea that maps
weren't particularly awesome and how we
could convince people otherwise so this
is a slippy map you can't see it sliding
because it's just an image but it's an
iso map of iceland and what that means
that has little iso lines that indicate
elevation so if you zoomed in you could
see those little iso lines you can kind
of see them over there where it's more
yellow but this was built in card ODB
which is the company that I worked for
before Mozilla and I worked on a bunch
of educational materials to teach people
how to build maps like this and a lot of
documentation on CSS to teach people how
to design maps like this it's beautiful
right you wouldn't necessarily use it
for location or wayfinding you wouldn't
hike across Iceland using this map but
but you can appreciate how beautiful and
artistic is and this is another one it's
a really bad jiff of
app that uses torque j/s which is a
library developed by cart 0 DB which is
now called card oh they just changed
their name like a couple of weeks ago
but it's a time series data map or
mapping library and what that means is
you can animate time series information
across a map if you have a time stamp
associated with any of your data so
these are tweets about the Indian
elections and they're colored according
to the candidates when people are
tweeting with certain hashtags you can
see like plumes of activity and where
people are pocketed that are more
interested in talking about a certain
candidate so you can also create these
kind of dynamic maps oh I'm sorry iTunes
I'm gonna have to quit you because
you're destroying the slides um yeah so
you can even do special cardo CSS hacks
for time series data which is very
exciting and I'll show you that in a bit
and mapmakers are really big on
mythology's like I talked about before
we kind of create stories that maybe our
little known in the wider web community
but are very well known in ours so this
is a place called null island it's at
0-0 coordinates so zero latitude zero
longitude which kind of falls just
beneath this little lip of Africa here
and it's kind of where everything geo
rectifies when you incorrectly set it up
in your data it will zero out and go to
the center and the center is Nell island
and it's this fictional place that we've
defined in most of our Maps so if you go
a nice easter egg on a lot of base maps
is if you zoom in really close to this
area you can find a null island and it's
usually shaped like this conventionally
people make t-shirts for this it has its
own Twitter it has its own flag you can
make it in sequel in cart 0 we built
this little example that uses sequel to
design an ISO map of null island that
you can then fork and use your
developments and somebody postulated on
the internet that because there are so
many projections on maps which are
different ways of viewing the world like
Mercator versus something else because
there are so many projections that are
actually
infinite null islands and it's a null
island archipelago and not an island so
people get really into the nerdiness of
it and and we love like building these
kind of stories right so it's not
necessarily as simple as a comic with
like very separate tiles we try to make
them as seamless as possible but the
story that you build in maps is very
analogous so I chose this just because
it's a part of a longer XKCD comic but
it includes a map and then also i
replaced the cryptography up there with
cartography because the way that you
built web maps a few years ago or 10
years ago is ah was very much like a
cryptographic a complex process and I'll
talk about that in a bit and how we
improved on it so how is this related to
comics well cardo CSS is kind of like
the onomatopoeia of maps it applies this
wow factor this POW this like
stimulation of movements and a dynamism
in ways that maps wouldn't have
naturally without some kind of CSS
properties and it makes it easier to to
access those kind of styles which we're
available before in XML and in other
formats but not as easy for developers
to grog so origin stories you talk about
origin stories with Superman or with
Wonder Woman so we'll talk about them
with Curtis ESS this is an architectural
diagram of components of osm and so I'll
talk a little bit about map Nick which
is the renderer of the tile renderer for
typical raster maps and I know what some
in particular post Chiss is like a
querying add-on on top of a Postgres
database and then up here openlayers and
leaf litter things you might be familiar
with if you've done any map development
on the web there is libraries and layers
that you can use for your base layers
and you can also swap in a lot of other
base maps so this is the kind of no
pseudo architecture that we dealt with
before and this part over here is kind
of how people edited osm or used to edit
osm now I think Matt box built a fancy
or GUI for it but ja 'some and pull
latch they have very tough names to say
but I just pulled this from and you can
get the link from the slides in the
comments this is part of a I think 54
slide deck that describes how to set up
a web map with osm and this is just the
part that talks about math Nick style
sheets so the XML style sheets that I
described before it's I think 10 some
slides and at the end of all of these
slides you finally get something that
says now that we've got all the
necessary software installed you need to
configure some of the software to work
correctly so even after installing it
it's still not going to work for you and
this is the kind of the process that you
had to go through with maps before right
so then came along all of these
companies that are super pro web
mattebox developed cardo CSS which is a
map Nick style preprocessor that
inherited from cascade Nick which is
like cascading style sheets but with the
map Nick end so they developed it and
developed a kind of gooey for dealing
with it called tile mill which they've
been deprecated and recently deprecated
crow CSS but other people have picked it
up so it's not totally dead stamen
designs beautiful base maps and they do
a lot of tutorials and things in carlow
CSS too so they make some very
sophisticated designs and they are
actually a contract company for places
who want to make very distinctive base
maps maps n is cool they're a company
that does a lot of WebGL like really
experimental advanced things under a
samsung grant that seemingly is endless
and there are awesome people who also
contribute to cart 0 CSS and then cardo
is a company that i used to work for
used to be called card ODB but they now
maintain the documentation and have
integrated cardo CSS into their default
GUI so those are the companies that are
kind of contributing to to this
processing community so if you're
editing in it in cardo if you're editing
a map in card oh I should say then you
get a GUI interface like this if you log
in you can also use the JavaScript
libraries and api's to access all of the
features of post just querying and cardo
CSS but but if you're just a regular
user trying to make a map
on the web in the browser then you can
use this interface which will let you
select different like buttons and colors
and things and then it will generate
curto CSS for you so you don't
necessarily need to know how to write it
but you can also edit CSS directly in
the kind of pull up tree on the side so
it looks sort of like this so you get
some like CSS where you have a sequel
tray as well that allows you to query
the data in your database in your
Postgres database and you can style it
and view it on the fly so the tiles kind
of update on the fly as you're editing
those things so this is the architecture
of that set up and I'm only mentioning
it because people like to know how
things are developed so this is how
cardo works at least they has an editor
interface on the right side and then
there's all of the libraries and api's
and set up for if you were going to
install cardo yourself and you don't
want to use the company as a host so
postgres posts just math neck you'll see
here to torque has its own render it's a
special renderer for time series data so
that's there there's red is for some
other things Maps API and sequel API
allow you to query your data as its
sword in Postgres and pull it into
anything so you could technically pull
it in as JSON and make charts and graphs
to you don't have to be bound to maths
and then the Maps API allows you to pull
particular maps that you've already made
in the GUI for example or that you have
stored and styled and here are a bunch
of JavaScript libraries this that jumps
around your map so you can create these
narratives torque is for time series
data Beck Nick is the vector tile
library that I'm going to be talking
about a little bit and then card ojs is
just the basic library for making maps
and cardo CSS fits somewhere along here
right it also is in the editor but but
if you're using the library's then you'd
want to include it so anatomy of
courtesy of that structuring your styles
courtesy SS is a little bit different
than regular CSS so with regular CSS you
have selectors for elements but with
carlos es su have selectors four
elements and data sets so if you have a
data set
null Island you can call that here and
then you can style particular aspects of
the data set and it allows you to do
nested styles you can create named
variables you can have attachments or
pseudo elements and I don't think
there's one here but I'll show one in a
bit that allows you to create glow
effects and it's pretty awesome when you
can kind of write pretty complex CSS
formats so here's an example for the
null island map this is an election map
for Knohl Island so we divided it into
districts and created a mix and another
party and each of those parties was
vying for election writes an island or
vote in el island and here's the CSS for
that it looks a little bit messy but but
it isn't and here's the pseudo elements
that I talked about so you can also
style labels I'll talk a little bit
about the symbolize errs to that you can
access in kurtal CSS I mentioned tidal
mill before it's been deprecated you can
still run it locally and you can still
create batch tiles but if you want to
create tiles on the fly you can use
cardo and they have a more sophisticated
setup now called turbo cardo which I'll
show you in a bit that allows you to
create automated ramps for CSS that are
quite sophisticated and I'm very cool so
turbo kardos like this you can create a
simple instead of having message styles
or if then statements like you see well
you don't see me if then but there's
lots of CSS there whoops and you can
collapse that into two one or two lines
with turbo cardinal so here's an example
to and if you look at the slides and
I'll also share the links at the end and
there's kind of this block that Raul
built that allows you to generate a lot
of different colors and styles and shows
you how turbo cardo kind of makes your
CSS more concise so symbolize errs are
superheroes with special properties maps
are composed of points lines and
polygons mostly if you're applying data
you're either creating countries or you
have points that your marketing or you
have lines like bike lanes or something
and then attached to each of these
symbolizes which have properties
are the geometries that they correspond
with so points lines and polygons or
sometimes raster's which are the image
ones that I mentioned before so you can
also style buildings you can style a lot
of components of your maps or your map
data in interesting ways so here's some
awesome maps let's go over some examples
of what you can do with cardo CSS for
simple styles this is a project very
simple project that I worked on in
Madrid there's an open data portal and
you can download a bunch of things but
they have a different spatial reference
system in Madrid then everyone else uses
and so they give you data but it's kind
of useless because when you load it on
to anybody's base map it's going to be
off slightly and in weird ways like
sometimes it's off this way sometimes
it's slightly moved over so when I
downloaded all of these bike lanes they
were slightly moved to the right and up
a little bit so I had to write some
sequel to move them back down but with
CSS you can also allow people to see
kind of glow effects around the biplanes
or at different zoom levels you can
create conditionals that allow people to
see more of the information at certain
zoom levels so what I have here is just
the CSS or the sequel for transforming
all of that data into the correct
spatial reference system and then some
simple CSS with a glow effect so this is
kind of the CSS that you would write for
something like this with red lines and
like a yellow an ugly yellow halo and
it's used in a project it's actually out
of 10 site is called bike storming or
spoke now they've renamed it but they
use glow lines in in their design of
bike lanes in different places this is
New York and you can apply layers of
data but all of their lines glow and
that's because they use those pseudo
selectors so base Maps base maps are
very cool stamen designs a lot of really
awesome ones the watercolor base map is
at the top and over here there's a
terrain base map and there's a
toner-based map and base maps are kind
of just like the base layer of of any
map without necessarily applying data on
top of it so sometimes it'll include
labels like the one
the center that has like places labeled
and sometimes it'll just include
features like the watercolor base map
and toner is the most basic of base maps
kind of like toner that you would I
don't know apply to your skin right to
clean the off it's like the most basic
and I picked these images from comics
because it shows some of the like
complexity of toner as a base map it
allows you to create patterns and to
erase patterns in buildings or roads or
whatever so you get different levels of
resolution with your map so for example
this one is kind of a little bit of a
hack but because the same and base maps
are built with cardo CSS you can also
use cardo CSS to override their defaults
so in this case you could make the
background colors transparent and only
save the labels or you could make like
the labels transparent oi that's a typo
but you could make the labels
transparent and only have like the rows
and features and this one is a little
bit more complicated but it's just
applying a pattern to the buildings
because remember buildings or symbolize
errs in cardo CSS so you can apply this
little hash pattern on them and you can
specify it as a PNG or whatever you can
also create some pretty interesting
patterns with sequel but that's apart
from caro CSS and here you can see the
zoom conditionals that i talked about
before you can also style on like if the
data if the area that's in a column in
your data set is above a certain amount
then you change the pattern or you apply
a different CSS style so you can create
this very interesting and complex
situations this is a project at a stamen
that's actually a browser-based project
you it limits you to four layers but you
can generate cardo CSS in the browser
and make your own base maps and then it
batch creates the tiles kind of like
what tile mill used to do so you should
check it out if you're interested in
that label magic so a lot of times when
you're zooming on maps you don't really
think about how everything adjusts so
naturally and seamlessly right all of a
sudden labels are appearing for certain
things as you're zooming closer and how
does that happen there are lots of
different ways to make it happen these
are a series of base maps that I'll show
that are used for Pinterest
so they have their own map design and
you can write little regex like rules in
CSS to say you know keep or hide the
text name keep it blank at a certain
level or in a certain circumstance with
a certain number of characters for
example so if there are too many
characters like maybe if this were a bit
longer and it wouldn't fit or conflicts
with another thing or there's not enough
space between the other two labels it'll
collapse them out and then also for
orientation sometimes there are places
that are a bit longer like California
Chile how are you going to write the
same name as you would for the other
states if it doesn't fit or for example
United States is here Kansas has to
twist to the side so you can create
rules that say like if the characters
are a certain amount twist it a certain
way and that's kind of a hack but but
you can do it composite operations
they're kind of like blend modes like I
think we heard about earlier today and
there are many of them that you can
apply you can create your own base maps
this way by layering data on top of the
regular base map so this is just several
I think it's for data layers with
different composite operations and it
creates a kind of bath you metric maps
so you can create depths in oceans based
on scientific information so that's
pretty cool and you should totally check
it out and then this is just an example
of the kind of base map effects you can
do so this is the base map I made very
quickly by just painting the whole
canvas blue applying a layer of polygon
information for countries and then
styling it white and then on top little
Argentina is like here you can see that
it has a little glow around it if you
look closely actually there's like a
blue glow around the so it stands out
from the rest of Latin America and this
is people tweeting about the elections
during the first election of Maori
Samaki and there's their hashtags
cambiemos I feel braver and so there was
an explosion of [ __ ] being lost at the
end
oh and here's the CSS for it so you can
create fills and backgrounds and blurs
so the image filters that you see here
too you can apply in curto CSS so
conditional zooms I talked about it a
little bit earlier so I won't really go
into it but you can create these kind of
conditional rules and you can do the
same for zoom levels so for the Madrid
cycleways at certain zoom levels lesser
than or equal to 16 for example it's one
color and then at 14 it's a different
color that's a pretty simple basic
example but there are lots of other
things you can do at different zoom
levels that you might want to do like I
said make make the labels disappear or
something and this is an example with
torque it has its own special properties
on pseudo properties and this is tweets
about Nepal it wasn't a kind of an
experiment we did to see how we could
maybe make the torque CSS of it easier
so I different zoom levels you want the
plumes are the offset of the bubbles to
be different because at some Zumba you
might want them to kind of overlap and
occlude each other and that another zoom
levels you want them to get kind of
smaller so they don't totally overwhelm
the screen so this is the kind of setup
that you would have for that a color by
category so for the null island election
map you would kind of create categorical
rules so there's a type of map called a
chloroplast map that maybe people have
heard of that colors regions or polygons
or points or even lines based on their
numerical value in the data set but for
categorical maps say you have votes that
are like yes or no those are strings you
can't create a claw reply that of that
you have to create a categorical map
which in this case is what happened so
the winning party column in the data set
if it was Nick's or if it was not it had
a different color and the labels were
the same so you can create those kind of
conditionals that style the the map that
way with not so much the SS and that's
then the result
so torque tile styling so I'll show a
few examples of what torque looks like
this is a project from info Amazonia in
Brazil they were tracking wildfires and
they wanted to kind of give these glow
effects to the torque points so you can
do this in CSS it's not just like the
plumes that you saw before with the
Nepal map it's a bit more like brilliant
and ensigns a bit you can also create
heat maps so this is a activity of snow
plows in Chicago with a tracker attached
to them and the person who designed the
map wanted to track to see where the
snow plows were going during snowstorms
because maybe an elected official lives
in an area that gets plowed all the time
and someone you know they don't plow the
poor areas because they don't care about
them so they ended up finding that there
was like a cluster over here I think
where there's a lot of activity and he
thought oh I bet there's an alderman or
governor who lives there and it turned
out it was just like a little snow plow
car park it was like where all the snow
plows went to bed and so it wasn't
actually a real story but it's still a
beautiful map right so this is a project
a euro bird portal that allows you to
kind of side by side view the migration
of certain birds as they've been
observed by the community along with
environmental factors like temperature
rainfall so you can see as it gets
warmer the birds move north and then as
it gets colder they move south again and
you can apply a bunch of other features
but you can do these the same kind of
things in torque you can do side by
sides you can coordinate them with the
open libraries with card ojs for example
and what else is looking to say about
this oh you can also do custom
projections so this is a custom
projection a group out of Catalunya was
leading this project and they wanted the
projection that makes Catalunya look the
biggest and the most profound so they
picked a different projection and this
is a project that layers torque on top
of a categorical map so the CSS rules
would mix between the two and it's just
openstreetmap edits of roadways in nepal
after the
after the earthquake so you can see kind
of like little plumes of activity this
is just an animated gif as people are
editing and all of the osm data is open
so you can download everyone's edits I
had to order it according to the time or
like the entry number that is
auto-generated and no sm because they
don't allow you to see the timestamps so
it's a bit of a hack to see where people
are editing over time but but these are
the kind of CSS rules so you have types
of different roadways as they're
categorized or tagged in osm and you can
apply colors to them so the CSS rules
would look like this and the sequel like
i said is ordering by the osm ID and for
the torque component it's doing all of
these things so there's a lot of like
special properties on the map element
for torque and mostly controlling like
the offset and the how big like the
trail is of the plume right now torque
is really good for points it's not super
great for polygons or lines you can't
like animate lines in the same way but
you can kind of do a hack that I'll show
you in a bit to sort of mimic polygons
with points so map Nick and Beck Nick
Beck nick is a vector tile render so
unlike map Nick which relies on tiles to
like forward next to each other and has
this slow load time vector mapping is a
lot more fast and sophisticated it also
allows you to the the geometries are
kind of more amenable to interaction so
you can apply like hovers and a lot of
other features that would be kind of
kludgy and difficult to get to render
with a raster map so you can do a lot
more animated things without loading
tiles so you should check out bec Nick
if you're interested so JavaScript
library and torque bubble maps so this
is kind of the hack that I talked about
that's sort of related to points so by
changing some aspects of of the torque
properties you can make points below to
cording to the data and look a little
bit bigger a little bit more like
polygons so it's
kind of more artistic interpretation of
what would be the default for torque
which is just everything kind of grows
in the same or plumes in the same way so
pop maps cardo CSS and it's compliments
because we're talking about pop art and
about comics I think this quote from
andy warhol's pretty good at
encapsulating how we behaved when we
worked on Carlos CSS at cardo there were
a lot of experiments torque was a like a
side project on the weekends a lot of
our some our core features were actually
just built over a few days with a few
friends so it's kind of whatever you can
get away with and a lot of the hacks
have been showing are things that
wouldn't necessarily be best practices
in cardo CSS but are definitely a way to
get something done if you need to and
there's a flexibility in what it will
allow to render so that's pretty awesome
so this for example this is not a map
but it's made with mapping software so
this is cardo the GUI interface i showed
you before but instead of having a base
map they just load it in a PNG an image
and then use torque to animate an
animated gif of a guide like jumping
over a thing so you can make stuff like
this to you can make web art with
mapping software and mapping libraries
so just for fun and for the pop art
example here's kind of weird map pack
that uses a click events to kind of
create onomatopoeia on a map so when you
click on certain states they kind of pow
like that but the cardo CSS for it
applies a pattern to the polygons so it
applies the under layer has this kind of
yellowish Ronald McDonald pattern and
then the other one on top is a bit more
red and creates like more contrast so
you can see them referenced here as P n
cheese you can do that in cardo as well
and this is the sequel to make it work a
lot it's pretty ugly it's pretty ugly
post kiss but on the credits gives us is
easy right let's like super simple and
concise
is kind of like glass but if you want to
do map interactive like click events
without using javascript you can do it
so I think this is a jiff that will
allow you yeah so you can see it just
like reloads it's not super
sophisticated but um but it does work so
you can do like weird stuff like that
like weird experimental art that isn't
really useful for navigation like we saw
before but is kind of fun I also run a
Twitter with a few co-workers called
Cardosi SS ponds that you should totally
follow that has a bunch of puns related
to cart 0 CSS some political pawns it
was one about Nell island somewhere down
here oh yeah but yeah display none you
should check it out and also I want to
plug if you're interested in learning
more about courtesy SS something my team
worked on a lot when I was at card ODB
was the math Academy and so we teach you
how to write post just functions how to
setup postgres yourself if you wanted to
self host we teach you about JavaScript
for maps we teach you about cardo CSS
and this particular lesson is about how
to make the election map for an
all-island so you should totally check
it out it has a video and a lot of cool
like demos and downloadable code so it's
very easy to approach and then at the
Mozilla science lab we also host a lot
of fellows so we have a fellowship
program that supports developers and
designers who want to write open source
software for science and this includes
the geospatial sciences like i said
before so if you want to make maps for
science or with scientific data then you
can totally do that one of our current
fellows worked on a project throughout
his fellowship called arial bold and it
uses satellite imagery and computer
vision to detect letter shapes from the
alphanumeric alphabet in natural
phenomenon like you know maybe a crop
circle that looks like as you know and
oh and then they built a web font arial
bold it's kind of a joke and if you go
to their little website you can type
message
is in satellite images and then send
them to your friends and so this kind of
like mapping hack projects is something
you could totally do with Mozilla
funding and we would invite you to do
really cool experiments for scientists
so please check out our fellowships and
come talk to me if you have any
questions about that and I guess in
summary i guess i would say try to make
pop maps as in pop art maps you know
maps that have a lot of onomatopoeia and
a lot of wow because those experiments
lead to sometimes the most awesome and
sophisticated features and aim for
awesome so before when I said that you
know maps were not built for all they
were built for navigation and
utilitarian purposes that's totally not
true and try to render with reflex which
i guess is more like how your eyes
render right try to think about how your
map is going to process for a user I
didn't talk about browser issues or our
support for low bandwidth situations
which can be really difficult for torque
or certain libraries but you can ask me
after if you're interested and so try to
do that and that's it
[Applause]
you